bruce willis he has been hunkered down
with his ex demi moore
but their quarren team just got bigger
now
that bruce's wife has joined the party
act like you like each other
one two three here we go the exes danced
and had a family paint night bruce
handled a quarantine cut shaving off
all of tallulah's hair and demi wore a
funny mustache
talk about a modern family for over a
month the divorced couple their children
and their boyfriends made the best of
isolation in idaho
so where was bruce's wife emma so my dad
came up here early and then travel got
crazy so my stepmom stayed in l.a with
my little sisters
so it's been really funny having both my
parents
at the house where they like raised us
this week
bruce's wife emma and their two
daughters finally arrived and look at
this
the whole demi bruce gang cheered as
bruce's daughter
evelyn who turned six on tuesday learned
to ride a bike
a source tells e.t it was a while to be
a part but the family is very happy to
be together again
and looks forward to spending quality
time together
you